μακαι θερογιατί υπήρχα ήμου και υπερόπτης με στα πολλά που είχα γράβοτα χάτε κφτά από
τούτ δσατα αποριθμήσουμε ιμουγκούμαρσίς μου εξωανίς ν άλκολικός οιμου κπνιστής ξέει στο αλαρκολικόκνή που άνκαι
πίνου δκαν πήρεστηνύχ αούνακαι αλκόκαι ξέρουν τη ημενικ αλκολικότα στην κύπρολοιπόν ήμουν η περόσημουν ενάρκις
αλλά πάνταέχα καλήν κατιά πάνταέχα κανεί καρπιά και ου αυθεντικό και πόέμναδεν ήμουν μαλλο επάνταθαήμουν
μουν μουν της αλήθειας και φαίνε ότι εβοήθησα τον πολλά το χριστόδουλίσρα ισχέσις σου μζί
του πιανη μιλάτ ή σταματήσεκοιτάξε έχι προσπαθώ εδώ προσπαθώς είναχς να τον πλήσει άσω προσπαθώς
ας ποτέλω του μηνήματα καματού μεχρί και ευγίτιο επροεδρέ φωνάξεμε για μου μέτο πρόεδρικό ότως
εβίδιο να κάψω μαζί σου εξιμίνεσα σου αλλάξοε κύπρ έτσι του το λέω και ενοότωτων
το πράμπολεέξι μήνεσα να που πάρασου τα κάμουλάα όπως πρέπει λοιπόν εξωτερική του πολύδική βαλλο
του δε καρίστα δε καρίστα είναι στι σωστή πλευρα της ιστορίας για μέαεξωτερικά χρεάζεται βοήθεια
πριαν πει να σε επιειρηματίας πρά που μια αλάγοντά του ναι χριστόφορεμο πανταμού που ενα
αρτ κύπροσου τηλεφωνίς έγάνε μου το πέντε φορές των το πράγμα ν ενατα ου τηλεφωνίς
οπονα αρτοανασου τηλεφωνίσω έχει πράγματα πουν πορούν να γίνουν να φύγησειστορία αν αλλάξουμετην κύπρο τότε
που εστρίξε τον νικό χριστ δουλίδη δεκτικες πολεμω σπάναια μουότι είχα και δεν είχαν υκαλα
μοα μέχριτό σαρφώ που χε πφέραμεσι την κύπρο κ που ποτε πιασα τιλεφωρώ το χριστοδουλίδη
ο οποιός χριστό δουλίδησε και καμετίποτα πια οντιλέη ιστορία μας άμε στο γεντικότη υθυντήν του
που έμαλλό α μετάξι α σα δρώμα του τώρα και αθρωπος γμε τη δουγιν τους
αν κράτος βασικά κ επκα και φέρα το έαα πκτει στη κύπρο πος έρκουντον λοιπό